>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Good morning again.
Buenos dias.
My name is Stephanie Marcus,
and I'm a research specialist
in the science, technology
and business division.
This is the first lecture of 2016,
and it's the first in our tenth year
of our collaboration
with NASA Goddard.
So it's been very fruitful, and
we were trying to choose talks
for this year and there
were so many good topics.
Normally we choose six, but we
couldn't resist, and we chose eight.
So it's going to be
a very busy year.
The next ones aren't till May, so
we have a little time to prepare
and since we had a snafu
today getting out speaker
into the parking lot,
we had plenty of time
to get the next one his parking.
Today our program is on
El Nino, as you know.
And our speaker is Steven
Pawson from NASA Goddard.
He came there in 1997, as a
meteorologist atmospheric physicist.
And he's been the Chief
of the Global Modelling
and Assimilation Office since 2014,
and has been on its
staff since 2003.
And if it's wrong, I got
this off the website.
So this man has a little
bit different background
from our other speakers.
He was educated in England
pretty much, and I think you are.
>> Steve Pawson: I'm English.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
British born, yes.
Let's see.
He spent almost a decade at
the Meteorological Institute
of the Free University of Berlin.
And he was also teaching
there for six years.
He was the editor for
several years for the Journal
of Geophysical Research
Atmospheres, which is published
by the American Geophysical Union.
He has a master's in atmospheric
sciences from Imperial College,
the University of London.
And a Ph. D in meteorology from
the University of Edinburgh.
He was a post-doc in space
and atmospheric physics
at the University of Oxford.
So he's well-educated.
And since we all think we know
a little bit about El Nino,
we're going to listen to a man who
knows everything about El Nino.
Welcome, Dr. Pawson.
>> Steve Pawson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Well, thank you for
the nice introduction.
I thought I was going to tell you
everything about El Nino today,
and when I first started
planning this presentation,
I was thinking I was going to show
satellite observations of clouds
in Ethiopia, how the monsoon goes
down in India, fires
in South America.
Flooding everywhere.
And when it comes down to it,
there's just so much
to say about El Nino.
I actually ended up dropping a lot
of those aspects from
the presentation.
I wanted to try to give just
a zoom-in on the Pacific Ocean
where El Nino is really happening.
And then a look at some of
the things that are happening
around the world because of that.
But really, I want to try to
give you a sense of a little bit
of how El Nino works, what it
really is and also how NASA has
so many satellite observations
that can contribute
to our understanding
of the phenomenon.
And also how we can use those with
numerical models to do predictions
of how things are going
to evolve in the future.
And in doing this I want to try
to give you that NASA and NOA play
in some ways similar but
actually very different roles.
And that NOA is an operational
agency, and they have a fleet
of operational satellites which they
can use and do long-term products.
NASA comes a bit more from the
space science point of view.
We're doing research
types of instruments,
so maybe some of them
are a little short-lived.
But they set up standards
and demonstrate
that observations can be
made of different processes.
And that they can be
used into the future.
And that I think gives
NASA an incentive
to continue the time series of
observations or it gives us a means
of convincing NOA to try to
take on that kind of observing.
And what I want to try to do
today is just give you a flavor
of how we work in that
regard, of how NASA makes sort
of revolutionary observations
at certain times.
And how we can use those to help
put together the big picture
of the processes at work.
I've tried to put a
little history in as well,
to try to show us how those people
from like a century ago were able
to just take a few points of
information spread over time
and put those altogether,
and actually understand pretty much
what we still understand today.
It's just that now we
have a lot more detail
from the number of
observations we have.
This is a slide.
I started collecting
things from newspapers.
I might be seeing a
little problem here.
And there's a lot of
-- over the world,
like different newspapers
are publishing stories
about El Nino's back and
droughts in Australia.
There's flooding in
Southern California.
A lot of El Nino related
damage in the Philippines
and Indonesia and things like that.
There's been a lot of
headline news about El Nino.
And also, has it been affecting
the droughts in California?
Has it been affecting
these big storms that came
up the east coast of the US?
And I'm thinking about that.
They all make the news and
get into the newspapers.
So my verview, which has an
O at the front of it usually,
is basically to say what is El Nino.
I'd like to give an overview
of what it looks like.
Yeah, I set the formats of these
slides on a stretched screen
and it's kind of truncated
on the 4x3 I think.
El Nino in history.
So look at the historical
observations, and then moving
into NASA's observations before we
go to the work that we actually do
in the Global Modelling
and Assimilation office,
which is using those observations
alongside computer models,
high-end computer models,
to make detailed analyses
of the three-dimensional
structure of El Nino.
And forecasts of how it's going to
behave over the next few months.
And then looking at the view
from space of different parts
of the climate system that
are affected by El Nino
and a little bit of
a summary at the end.
So start off with a basic
description of El Nino.
What is El Nino?
And basically looking at the oceans
and the signals that El Nino has.
So I'm going to start with a map
of global sea surface temperature.
So this is what's called a Robinson
projection, so it goes in a bit
at the poles and it gives
you roughly the sense
that the tropics are very large.
And if we look at this map --
This doesn't seem to be working.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Just press that button.
>> Steve Pawson: That one?
The red one?
That helps, yeah.
Okay, so there we go.
So this is sea surface temperature
and basically the Reynolds sea
surface time series is a very
famous product.
It's developed at NOA.
And it's used to produce essentially
global maps at least every month
of the temperatures of
the surface of the ocean.
And to see what you expect.
At the poles where there's
less sunlight, it gets cooled.
It's cold so those
temperatures are blue.
They are just in the
low few Celsius.
Then by the time you
get to the tropics,
you can see the temperatures
are well into the 20's Celsius.
Much warmer water.
And in particular what
we'd like to look at today
in this region of the Pacific Ocean.
And we can see that
over by Indonesia,
the maritime continent north of
Australia in the western Pacific,
the temperatures really
are up to above 28 Celsius.
And that's kind of a magic number.
Because 28 Celsius is about the
temperature that we need to have
for deep, powerful
convection to happen.
So basically over that region we're
going to get strong clouds forming,
very deep clouds and storms.
And in the normal case, there's a
lot of precipitation in this region.
And we can see what's called the
intertropical convergence zone,
which is essentially a warm tongue
extending over to the east Pacific.
That hits Central America.
And if we look right on the equator,
we can see cooler waters
here off the coast of Peru.
And that is associated with
the currents we'll talk
about in a few moments.
But this is the basic structure of
temperature over the Pacific Ocean.
Warm on the west, cooler
on the east.
At least in the southern hemisphere
and under the equator itself.
There's that gradient.
And that's essentially the normal
state of the circulation over there.
And this is basically
pointing out what I just said.
And this black rectangle
is essentially showing us
that the main region of
interest for El Nino --
so when you think about it,
it's the tropical Pacific Ocean.
But this projection does a fairly
good job of preserving areas.
This is actually about between
30 north and 30 south is half
of the globe in terms
of surface area.
And this is almost half of that in
terms of the longitudinal extent.
So El Nino is a huge thing.
It's affecting -- variations
in El Nino are really affecting the
global temperatures because it's
such a large area of the
globe that we're looking at.
What we tend to show when
we're looking at El Nino
and other phenomena is the anomaly.
And that's the departure from the
long-term average in this sense.
So we look at an average from
something like 1980-2000 and we do
that and we subtract that from the
actual year that we're looking at.
And that's essentially telling
us how different is this year
from a normal year, if
a normal year exists?
And this is December of 2013
again, the month that we just saw.
And we can see that in
this tropical region here,
there are really very
small differences
from the normal situation here.
So this is what we
call a neutral year.
There was no El Nino
and there is no La Nina.
Yeah? We're not going to talk
too much about La Nina today.
La Nina is essentially just an
intensification of the normal state.
So where it's cold over here and the
average is just a little bit colder
than normal average, and probably
a little bit warmer over here.
The more interesting one is the
El Nino, and this is the plot
from the previous December,
2015, the one that just passed.
And here we can see a
very different situation.
Now we've got a slightly cool
anomaly over the western Pacific,
but here over the eastern
Pacific we can see a very,
very large red colored contour
that's showing us temperatures more
than two degrees above
the typical situation.
And this is the development
of the El Nino case,
where the warmth has basically moved
across the Pacific
to the other side.
And now south of the equator
in Peru there's these warm
ocean temperatures there.
And that's showing
up as that anomaly.
There are other features you
can see too in the other oceans.
But they are less of
a concern today.
Except one thing here.
I'm just going to talk
back to the 2013 case.
Already we're seeing
this very warm anomaly
in the Pacific Ocean off
the west coast of the US.
And that's been referred
to quite a bit in the press
as the blob and things like that.
It's basically a warm anomaly
off the coast of California
and the entire west coast here.
And this is probably related to the
drought that we've been experiencing
in California and on the west
coast over the past few years.
This has been quite persistent.
And it's led to the
anomalously low rainfalls
over the west coast,
the site of the drought.
Or if it hasn't led to it,
it's associated with it.
It's all part of the same sort
of large-scale sort of patterns
of variations in the atmosphere.
And you can see when
we go back to 2015,
that's still apparent there as well.
And that's probably going to be
important just towards the end
of the presentation when we
talk a little about California.
So that's essentially what I
wanted to show at the beginning.
Now just one more thing.
If we look at this map here,
we can see that this is directly
compiled from observations.
So observations are
coming in from ships.
They're coming in from
satellite observations
of the ocean temperatures.
And from satellites
especially, they're very spotty
because there are a lot of clouds
in the way and things like that.
So you can see that spottiness
come through on these maps.
Especially outside the tropics, it's
got a bit of a spotty structure.
Whereas on this plot, this is
essentially the same field,
just using the same
observations more or less
with a few extra ones added.
This is what happens
when we actually assimilate
those same observations.
And essentially assimilation is
the art or mathematics really
of putting together observations
into a very complex computer model.
And we're essentially, if you
interpolate you'd have information
about this point here
and this point here
and you could draw a straight
line between them and come
up with some values from in between.
What assimilation is
essentially doing is a very
sophisticated interpolation.
And the model that we're
using to build that structure
in between the observation
points is based
on the dynamical equations
of motion.
So we're actually using
that to use water masses
around when we do it for the ocean.
And that gives us a good estimate
of the state of the ocean based
on the observations in other places.
So it's essentially a very expensive
three-dimensional interpolation
that we're doing to come
up with optimize analyses
of the entire globe.
And we'll see later we get the
three-dimensional structure
of the oceans as well from
just a few bits of information
about the vertical
profiles in the ocean.
And the point here being if we
toggle back and forth for a moment,
here it's very noisy from
the pure observations.
Here we get a much smoother and
much more sort of realistic,
dynamical looking field that's
taking into account the motions
of the ocean currents and the
surface winds blowing over it
that help define these fields.
And so that's essentially the
work that the Global Modelling
and Assimilation office
is doing in this.
And here again, as part of what
we do, this is showing us sections
across the equator from the
Indonesian side of the Pacific
to the South American
side of the Pacific.
And it's showing depth
of the ocean froM0
to about 300 meters
below the surface.
And this is the temperature anomaly
as a function of depth of the ocean
for December of 2013 where
we see just a very weak one
or two degree -- region that's one
or two degrees warmer than normal.
And for December of 2015,
the strong El Nino year
that you saw at the top.
And here you can see that
this temperature anomaly
that we were looking at on the
surface just a moment ago is really,
really prevalent below the surface.
And it reaches about
7 degrees Celsius
on this South American
side of the Pacific.
So under the ocean surface.
Now as I said, this analysis
is made using the surface
ocean observations.
It's made using an analysis
of the atmospheric state
so we know the winds in some detail.
And it's also made using
just very, very few profiles
of the ocean temperature and
salinity structure from some buoys
that are moored over in the
Pacific at certain locations.
But really it's just a handful
of information that's
actually measured about that.
And we use the model to
fill in the gaps and come
up with a three-dimensional picture.
The other thing that
we sometimes use,
and I actually believe it's
actually not in this run,
but we sometimes use measurements
of the sea surface height
that we made from space.
And we'll be looking
at those in a while.
And essentially that's
useful because obviously
from space you can't see below the
surface of the ocean in most cases.
Especially optically thick.
So all you can do is
measure the top temperatures.
One thing you can measure
at the surface,
if you can measure the height of
the ocean you're essentially saying,
"If that water in there is warm,
it's going to have a larger volume,
so it's going to push
the height up."
So these surface height observations
are telling us about the temperature
of the water over a huge, deep
layer beneath the surface.
And so that's the type
of thing that can go
into getting this analysis as well.
And so moving away from
that and going back to kind
of the schematic -- and
it's always tempting to try
to draw my schematics
of what's happening.
And actually these days if you look
around the web you really
find some fantastic ones.
And this one I think
sums up what's happening
and what we've just talked about.
It's essentially showing
the ocean surface,
showing the normal warm temperatures
over to the western
part of the Pacific.
And then the deep convection
above that, and this circulation
in the atmosphere that
goes up in that region
and it completely goes
across and down.
And then the trade
winds they're called,
running across the
ocean's surface up there.
And that's called the trade winds
because of the ancient shipping
routes that sailors used to make use
of those to get across the Pacific.
Essentially they'd be
blown across there.
And it's showing underneath
the ocean surface,
it's showing the thermocline.
The thermocline is essentially the
boundary of the water that's mixed
up by turbulence caused
by wind stirring it.
And the deep ocean waters,
which are not affected
by the surface winds so much.
And so what we're seeing is that
the thermocline is not far below the
surface on the Indonesian side.
But then on the Peruvian side
here there's basically upwelling.
We'll talk about that
again in a moment.
And that's pushing the
cold, nutrient-rich water
from the deep ocean
upwards on the coast.
And so the layer that's
actually affected
by the atmosphere is very thin
at that edge of the ocean.
So that's the normal state.
And then if we look at the El
Nino state we can see the warmer
temperatures moving
across the equator.
The thermocline tips so we don't
get so much of the upwelling
over the eastern side
of the Pacific.
And the deep convection
in the atmosphere moves
over to the central Pacific
and also a little bit more
over to the South American
part of the atmosphere.
And as I said earlier, the La
Nina case, which is the opposite
of El Nino, is basically an
intensification of this state.
And typically the thermocline may
even meet the surface just off
the coast.
So it's just an intensification
of how cold it is over that side
of the Pacific and a little
bit warmer over the other side.
And I've tried to give a citation
to most of the figures I do use
from the web, although this is --
I think that's the original site.
These images float
around all over the place,
so it's hard to know
who did that one first.
So just looking at this, the Pacific
then essentially, in normal years
in the central Pacific
region we've got sort
of moderately warm temperatures.
In El Nino years it
gets much warmer.
And this is then used as a metric of
how strong the El Nino events are.
These four regions, Ninos
one, two, three and four --
the red shaded regions --
early locations used to define the
strength of the El Nino events.
And the reason they're called one,
two, three and four I think is
because these are places
where the ships used to sail.
And so they actually made
measurements using --
you know, they threw a bucket
over the side, pulled the water up
and put a thermometer
in it, basically.
And they get measurements of
the ocean surface temperature.
And that's still done
today by research vessels.
And so these were four
regions where ships sailed.
And it's obviously due to
trades between the ports
of South America here and the
Asian ports on these lengths.
What we typically use these days
to define the El Nino is
this region we call Nino 3.4,
which has got a little bit of
4 and a little bit of three.
And I think people
converge on that just
because it really shows a
decent signal that we can relate
to what we regard as Enzo.
And then if we look at the time
series of the Nino 3.4 region,
this is essentially showing us
how things change over the years.
This one begins in 1950, and it
goes up to actually the present,
to about February of 2016.
This is again compiled by NOA.
There's this one of the
labs in College Park.
And essentially you can
see these very cold years.
Basically if it gets half a
degree cooler than normal,
it then turns into La Nina, at least
if it persists for three months.
And if it gets half a degree
warmer than normal and persists
for three months, then
it's regarded as El Nino.
And of great interest are these
three big El Nino events in 1982-83,
'97-98 and then this present year.
You can see that at least over the
last 50 years these three events
stand out.
And this one was quite
widely studied
and it's a very interesting
one in many ways,
because it actually coincides
with a major volcanic
eruption as well, El Chichon.
So it's actually hard to use
that to decide what the
climate anomalies are,
especially with El Nino,
because there are also big
climate anomalies associated
with all the volcanic
sulfates and all
that buzzing to the high atmosphere.
So that one is less useful,
at least less useful in terms
of defining climate anomalies.
But as we get through to 1997-98,
we're getting to the point
where we have a fairly clean
atmosphere so we can look
at the climate anomalies.
And the other great thing
is this is around the time
when NASA did start having some
research satellites available.
And in particular the TRIM mission
that measured global
precipitation had just been launched
when this started.
And we also had some measurements
of the color of the ocean,
which tells us about
how many phyto pints are
in it and things like that.
So this starts to get
interesting for NASA.
And then of course the
present one is as strong
as by this measure that one.
In some measures it's
a little stronger.
In other measures it's
not quite so strong.
So this again is giving us an
opportunity to look at El Nino
with a very modern fleet
of satellite instruments alongside
everything else that we have.
And I think just basically
the forecasts
of this extremely strong
El Nino that started coming
out towards the middle of
last year were really alarming
because people remembered what
happened with the 1997-98 one.
You know, that was a big,
global scale climate response.
It starts with that
warm water by Peru.
Really leads to a lot of
anomalous rainfall in Peru.
A lot of rainfall in a
mountainous terrain like that leads
to a catastrophic landslide.
So a lot of environmental damage
by the flooding and landslides.
So there was a lot of concern about
that happening this year as well.
And I was going to show a bit
more about that, but I didn't.
And so I'll say now that actually,
even though there was some
strong rainfall in Peru,
it didn't turn out
to be quite as bad.
Because if we look at these
anomalies, El Nino one
and El Nino two are
basically telling us
about the temperatures just by Peru.
They were not quite so strong
this year as they were in 1997-98.
So essentially there's been
a tendency for the El Ninos
to be peaking in more of the
central pacific rather than right
on the eastern Pacific
in recent years.
Even though this one is really big
and bigger in some ways than '97-98,
its horizontal extent
wasn't quite as large.
So it didn't have such a
big signature down here.
That means that any weather
systems that are moving
into Peru just don't
get quiet as much energy
from the oceans beneath them as
they go in a little less water
because it's not quite so warm.
And so the rain has
probably not been quite
as bad as it was in '97-98.
That's not to say there hasn't
been any severe storms in Peru,
but it probably wasn't as
bad as they were dreading
in the beginning of this.
So with that, I've tried
to give sort of an overview
of the basic characteristics of
El Nino and what it looks like.
I want to just briefly
go through a little bit
about the historical
role of El Nino.
And it seemed good to start
with an old map of Peru.
So that's the Peruvian coast, and
you can see that north is pointing
that way, so orientate yourself.
And this is actually -- this map
was actually drawn up by Mercator
and one of his colleagues.
And there's actually a Mercator
map projection that's you know,
very widely used to this day.
It's essentially a regular
latitude/longitude grid.
And you know, you really --
I just always found it
impressive these people would be
out on ships and making
measurements.
And they'd get some fairly
accurate maps of the coast.
They even put ships out in
the sea and things like that.
You know, sometimes
you find monsters.
I don't know about these ones.
So this is a nice one.
And you can see on this too
they've really made effort
to show the very tall
mountains, the Andes,
very close to the coast in Peru.
Which rise very dramatically
up there.
So that's an old map.
And this is a map of basically the
ocean circulation of South America.
Again, a pretty old map.
This is the coast of South America.
And essentially the Humboldt current
runs up the coast in the ocean.
And as we get close to the
equator, that starts to be pushed
by the winds going
off the continent.
Also by the earth's rotation, kind
of encourages that to flip away.
So as we get to Peru and Ecuador,
that current is moving
away from the coast.
And that's essentially dragging
this water up from below.
So that deep water from the
deep cold ocean is going
to get drawn up from the deep ocean.
And that comes up just around here.
And as the settlers in the 17th
century and way back started moving
into Peru, they basically started
discovering that there was a lot
of fishing, especially
anchovies off the coast.
And essentially what's happening
there is this cooler water that's
upwelling from the ocean floor is
bring up iron and other nutrients.
And that encourages the growth
of phytoplankton in that water.
It's got plenty of
light to grow as well,
so it's really the ideal conditions.
And these anchovy fisheries
are essentially still one
of the biggest fish sources
for the entire world.
But what actually happened is
that the old fisherman noticed
that every few years
the fish would go away.
And this is basically
the ocean warms.
This is the El Nino coming in.
The ocean warms.
That upwelling of the deep cold
waters to the surface is cut off.
The phytoplankton, you know,
they're upwelling somewhere else.
So the fish go away
and feed elsewhere.
So essentially there's a
dramatic decline in the fisheries
in those years when
there's an El Nino.
And the name El Nino
actually comes --
it was given to it by the Spanish
settlers in Peru and Ecuador.
Essentially this was happening
around the end of the year,
around Christmastime and they used
to call this the boy
child, or El Nino.
And that's where the
name comes from.
And then La Nina, I think the
name came some years later
because it wasn't so dramatic.
You know, you still got
the fish in the La Nina.
So for those people
it wasn't so critical.
And so that's loosely
how things are working
around the coast of South America.
And just flipping onto a very
modern view, this is a NASA view.
This is actually from the CWB
Satellite which was observing
around 1997 and 1998 after
it was first launched.
So CWB measures the color
of the ocean essentially
at different wavelengths.
And the color of the ocean, if it's
very green, means there's a lot
of phytoplankton in there.
If it's very blue, it means it's
very clean so there's no life.
So you can infer from
this the amount
of phytoplankton in the ocean.
And you can then infer where the
fish may be and things like that.
But these plots are essentially
showing that in December of 1997,
an El Nino year, we have to look
at the scale and be careful here.
This is a logarithmic scale here.
So this dark blue has 10 times less
chlorophyll than this pale blue.
And by the time you get to
white, that's 100 times less.
So between there and there,
there's about 100 times
less chlorophyll here
than there is there, basically.
And this is the El Nino year.
You're seeing not particularly much,
but compare that to
December 1998, a year later.
So '97 was the first year
of measurement from CWB.
'98 you're seeing a
very white region.
So you're in the few
milligrams per cubic meter
of chlorophyll in those regions.
So we're essentially able
to show using space-based
measurements the thing
that the Peruvian fishermen
knew all those years ago,
that the phytoplankton had
gone away in the El Nino event.
And there they are in
the La Nina in this case.
So you can actually
see this from space.
And we've now got a
really long time series.
About 20 years of measurements
of ocean color.
And there's a new mission
that just got funded to take
that way into the future.
So you know, we're able to do
sort of climatological studies now
of ocean color and infer
phytoplankton changes over time.
We have models that run
and do sort of diatom
and multi-bodied phytoplankton
that kind of change over time.
And that's one of the great
things that we actually do
with our satellite observations.
So going back to history,
and we come to Sir Gilbert
Walker who is also English.
He was a mathematician and physicist
and essentially he was posted
to India as the director of the
meteorological observatories there.
And he just heard about,
you know, there had been --
I'm sorry, I'm not saying this well.
In the late 19th century there
had been famines in India
because the monsoons had collapsed.
And Walker knew about other things.
He knew about pressure measurements,
surface pressure measurements
over the Pacific Ocean.
And he basically had an army
of staff in India working
on time series analysis essentially.
And what we now do very routinely
on the computer he had
people doing for him.
And he was able to establish
sort of relationships
between different variables
that were being measured
in the atmosphere in that time.
And it turns out that the
circulation with the ascent
over Indonesia and then the
transport across the atmosphere
and descent near South America,
that's now called the Walker
circulation, named after him.
And he's basically the person
that put this all together.
And what he actually defined
was what's called the southern
oscillation, which was a
seesaw in surface pressure,
the surface pressure
difference between Tahiti
in the min-Pacific and
Darwin in Australia.
So he was able to deduce that
those things moved out of phase.
And this was the change
of mass of the atmosphere.
He didn't realize at that
point that that was El Nino.
It was Burke I guess in the 1950's
or '60's who put that all together
and realized that essentially
the southern oscillation
in the atmospheric surface pressures
is essentially the same signal
as the El Nino event in
the tropical Pacific ocean.
You know, but coming
up with these things
with just a few point measurements
of meteorological conditions
of the colonial sort of stations
that they had set up over time.
So this is a much more modern map.
It was in the 2007 IPCC report.
And it's showing essentially this
Darwin sudden oscillation index,
the Tahiti Darwin surface
pressure change.
And in this case actually we
have to be a little bit careful.
A positive value is
actually La Nina.
A negative value is an El Nino.
They're anti-correlated
between them,
the Pacific surface temperature.
But essentially what it's
saying is that when we have a --
so a negative anomaly in this
pressure difference is corresponding
with -- this will be a positive
anomaly in the surface temperature.
So the El Nino has
warmer temperatures
over the eastern Pacific than
has that particular signal
in the surface pressure difference.
So you can see a signal
here in the surface.
That temperature in
the surface pressure.
This is essentially
the Walker circulation.
When it's going up there,
the pressure is lower.
Down here the pressure is
higher and that seesaws.
And the precipitation,
essentially the clouds are moving
over the mid-Pacific
in the El Nino event.
So in the El Nino the
precipitation is increased
in the mid-Pacific over Indonesia.
So that's the coherent
dynamical framework.
Walker put that together.
You know, we've got a lot more
observations and a lot more time
to have done that in the meantime,
but that still holds
in those things.
So that's then showing essentially
what people were able to do
in historical times with
very few observations.
And now let's move a little into the
time when we have NASA observations.
And I want to emphasize the view
from space showing the advantages
that a satellite can have over
these in situ observations.
We start with just repeating
the map of where we're looking
in the El Nino 3.4 region.
And this time, I'm going to show
the historical ship tracks as well.
This is obviously not
NASA observations.
This is ship observations that
were made I think towards the end
of last century.
And this is averaged
over a long time,
so there are a lot
of tracks in that.
And unfortunately the
Pacific on this is over here.
But you can see there's
the coast of South America.
You can see fairly dense
networks of ships off Peru.
And then crossing the trade winds,
crossing the Pacific
and coming into Asia.
You can see, you know, there's some
very interesting things about this
because the ships, if they
wanted to go around here,
they had to go all the way around
the Cape, so going past Africa.
So if we look then at a more modern
ship map, we can see the Panama
and Suez Canals have opened up
and that has totally
changed where the ships go.
You know, the distances are
much shorter going through.
So really very few ships now
are going through these regions.
But many more are passing through
the channels, through the Red Sea,
through the Mediterranean and
then through the Panama Canal.
But still, the point being
for both the historical time
and the present time, yes, you
do get quite a lot of information
from ships, but it's
very, very selective
where you actually
have that information.
It's analogous really to the weather
observations that we have, you know,
for the weather forecasts.
Essentially we have a lot of
balloon observations over land,
so North America, Europe, Asia
is all dense in observations.
But really very, very few
of those over the oceans
because there is no one
there to observe things,
and similarly in unpopulated
land regions,
don't have many observations
there either.
So essentially, knowledge
of surface temperature
from ships is essentially only
coming from where the ships sail.
So what NASA does is
basically provide a lot
of different types of observations.
I'm actually going
to skip this slide,
and I'm going to show
this one, maybe.
And this is basically
showing NASA has
about 20 satellites
in orbit right now.
Most of them polar orbiting,
which means that they essentially
just go round and round and round
in a circle and the earth
spins underneath them.
And because the earth turns once
a day, we basically get a map
of things high-globe from
each satellite over each day
when it's in a polar orbit.
And this is the fleets.
You can see some of them
chasing each other around.
That's actually called the A-train.
[Laughter] That's the name.
Basically, they're all trying
to measure essentially the same
air masses, one after the other,
so we get information about
different properties of it.
What one interesting one, it's
always the same with this movie.
As soon as you want to start
speaking about something,
it disappears around the back.
So there's the Space Station.
There, it's gone again.
But a very different type of orbit
is the International Space Station.
Here it comes around there.
So that's in a much different
orbit, it's much more inclined,
so it's essentially going around
the earth more frequently.
What that means is you actually,
whereas these polar orbiters,
you only see one time of
morning and one time of night,
the Space Station, you basically
go through the whole day,
and you can see things
at all times of day.
And that can be really
useful information for things
that vary strongly through
the day, if you're able
to see them from that orbit.
No, and you know, a
whole bunch of things
that [inaudible] you
just sort of go by.
That's actually a radar, and
it's measuring the roughness
of the ocean's surface so you're
able to get information about waves
and things like that from that.
Oh, seems to have stopped.
You know, OCO2 down there
is measuring carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere.
SNAP, which seems to have gotten
distorted as well as stopped,
is measuring soil moisture
from space.
That's a fairly new
mission, you know.
And actually, we had one
called Aquarius up there.
That failed, unfortunately,
last August.
We're hoping we're going to be able
to use some measurements from SNAP
to replace Aquarius
and get information
about the surface salinity of the
oceans, the saltiness of the oceans.
And that's also a really
important part of the like,
the circulation budget, essentially
you've got cold, fresh water coming
as ice melts in high latitudes.
And also, you know,
colder water comes up.
I'm sorry, and then where
it rains onto the oceans,
that's diluting salt, so
it's fresher there as well.
So with things like that, we're able
to put together a big picture of,
you know, how precipitation's
happening
and how it's affecting the ocean.
How if ice is melting
in the polar regions,
that's affecting the
salinity of the oceans.
And that's sort of what drags the
large-scale ocean's circulations
that we have.
I wanted to talk a little bit
about the sea surface height.
I alluded to that earlier.
As I said, you basically can't
measure temperature below the
ocean's surface from space.
So, but what you can
do is kind of infer
that if it's warm, it's
going to be higher.
So essentially, this
series of satellites,
they're actually international
partnerships with Europe,
and they're led by the jet
propulsion laboratory in California.
We've just launched Jason-3,
which is the third one
in the series of Jasons.
Jason-2 was launched in
2008, Jason-1 in 2001.
And before that, we had
TOPEX/Poseidon which was launched
in 1992 and lasted through 2006.
So we've got a long time series now
of about 20 years of information
about the height of the oceans.
And this is a, you know, as I said,
sort of an integrated quantity
of the vertical temperature profile.
And this is an example
of, again, an anomaly map
for February 22nd of this year.
So really quite recent.
And it's showing us essentially the
same thing that we've been looking
at with the temperatures.
Where it's warm, we've
got a high anomaly
in the oceans' surface, you know.
So it's warm, it's
thicker, it's raised up.
And here over the Eastern
Pacific, it's lower than normal.
So that's the signature of the
El Nino in the ocean height.
Now how we measure that is
actually very interesting.
Essentially you, you -- you would,
the altitude of the spacecraft
is measured very accurately
in reference to a certain geoid,
it's called, a reference level.
And then by beaming a radar down,
it knows how much signal is sent.
It times the time for it to come
back, the signal to come back.
And then it can calculate the
path between the spacecraft
and the height of the ocean.
So with those two pieces of
information about the height
of the satellite above this
reference level, and the distance
from the satellite to
the ocean's surface,
which you can measure
very precisely,
it can actually measure the height
of the ocean's surface to within --
I think it's about
three centimeters.
From an orbit about -- I
think it's about 300 --
no, 850 kilometers above
the earth, 500 miles up.
So, you know, that's the type of
information we can get from space
that we cannot get from down here.
You can't actually measure
the height from down here.
You'd be on a ship, and you don't
know how high you are to start with.
Yeah, so. And another type of
observation that we can make.
This is actually rainfall,
and again,
it's comparing the rainfall
measurements on the left
for 2014, on the right for 2015.
And it's two different months.
I think it's September and October.
September at the top,
October at the bottom.
And if you look at this carefully,
you can see the differences
with the El Nino states.
And when you look at it from here,
you can't see any difference at all.
And so maybe we'll just
skip over that one.
There is definitely a signal of --
it's actually difficult to
get the reference there.
I should stand near
the microphone, sorry.
It's essentially, I
think that's the equator,
and this is closer to
the equator than -- .
I'm sorry.
This is side in 2015, are closer
to the equator than these ones.
And you can see actually,
yeah, it is more red
over the mid-Pacific
than it is here.
So, you know, there's -- if you
know what you're looking for,
you can actually see the signal
of El Nino in those observations.
And those really are just two of
the different types of observations
that we have from NASA that
help us put together sort
of a quantitative picture
of what's really happening
in the El Nino event.
Now the ocean height,
that goes along
with the sea surface temperature
that we actually get
from NOA largely.
And this again, the Global
Precipitation Mission,
the TRMM was a predecessor of
the Global Precipitation mission.
If you remember, that's
the one that crashed
into the Indian Ocean
about a year ago.
It ran out of fuel, and
then it just basically --
they descend back through
the atmosphere then.
But now there's the Global
Precipitation Mission
which should give us information
about rainfall and clouds
for the next few years as well.
So I wanted to give a brief look
at our computer-based analysis
and prediction, and I
see I'm actually running
out of time a little bit,
so I have to be careful.
But essentially, I already
mentioned we're taking a lot
of these observations that are
made from earth and also combining
that with observations from space,
and using advanced analysis
techniques to come up with analyses
of three-dimensional
structure of the oceans,
as well as the atmosphere.
And once we have a good estimate
of the ocean's state on any day,
we can actually start to
predict what it's going
to look like in the future.
So every month we 'rerunning a suite
of forecasts that's
called an ensemble.
I think right now we run
17 numbers each month.
Some of them start
on different days,
and some of them we tweak the
actual state because, you know,
there is some uncertainty in it.
So we try to build up
some suite of ensembles
and then we can make a forecast.
And these are then the forecasts
that we ran last August.
We'd already in about May, we'd been
starting to see a signal of a very,
very strong positive temperature
anomaly in this Nino 3.4 region.
And this is the ensemble.
Often, when you run an
ensemble, this is the zero line
that you'll get if
you're going up there,
and if you're going down there.
And, you know, the average of
them all is roughly what you put
out as the best guess of
where we're going to go.
In this case, we'd already
seen the observations
of sea surface temperature ramping
up, so we want to start with,
and we're predicting
then, a very warm anomaly.
That's about, you know, three and
a half degrees on the average,
but some of them were almost five
degrees, and most of them were
about two and a half degrees.
So we were predicting fairly
early on a very strong El Nino
for this year, and we were a bit
worried about it because some
of the other centers weren't
predicting something that strong.
But actually it turned out as the
year went by, the Australians put
out a press release
saying it's going
to be the strongest El Nino ever.
And it sent out these
two or three groups
that were forecasting a very strong
event, and were actually right.
And this is what's called the
National Multi-Model Ensemble.
This is a project organized by NOA,
and they gather this information
from different centers
that make the forecasts.
And what I just showed
you from out groups is all
of the different ensemble members.
You can then make an average for
each group, and this is the averages
for each of a number of groups.
We're on this with the yellow one.
We are the strongest number;
one of the Canadian
models is a little weaker.
And the average is here.
Most of the models were
clustered just a little bit colder
than the average of all
of them, and that's just
because you have two
fairly high ones above it.
So you know, there was a
good consensus this year
that there was going to be a very
strong El Nino, and you know,
in the mid-Pacific, it really looked
like it was going to
be the strongest one.
This is a, this is a history map
showing our forecasts that began
in August of each year,
so essentially you're seeing this
El Ninos and La Nina's going along.
This was, the blue line
here is the observations,
those Reynolds Sea Surface
Temperature observations,
and here -- so here you are
in January and February.
It's very warm.
And here is our forecast.
So we'd greatly overestimated
that forecast
in that previous event
in '97 and '98.
But generally, you know, we
do a reasonably good job,
and we were a bit concerned
about this one being so strong
because on the basis of this one,
we were thinking, "Well, okay,
we're saying it's strong, but
it's going to be down here."
But actually, and unfortunately,
I couldn't find the
plot that shows it.
But we actually did
a pretty good job.
This was one of the strongest El
Ninos ever in the mid-Pacific.
So these forecasts of
sea surface temperatures
in that region were pretty accurate.
And so what's going to happen now?
We've gone through this time.
We've predicted a big El Nino,
now here are the forecasts
that begin in January of 2016.
Here you can see we're in the pink
now so we're up there somewhere,
the two and a half, three degrees.
And as time goes by, we're
predicting that to fall away
and just get loosely negative.
So essentially, the
El Nino's dying out.
Some of the groups are now
predicting a, you know,
a reasonably strong La Nina event
is going to happen later this year.
On the basis of this
we couldn't really say
that our ensemble is doing that.
But you know, that's
still a possibility.
There's often a precedent that when
you have a strong El Nino event one
year, the following year you
get a reasonably strong La Nina
event afterwards.
So this is like an
over-recovery of the thing.
So that's one of the uses of the
analyses, making these forecasts.
What I'd like to show now is
a movie, and this is going
to show us the sea
surface temperatures.
And throughout 2015, and this is
the view from the top, essentially,
so this is from our analyses,
and it's showing essentially
how the warmth has built up
and propagated across the ocean.
This is made from daily
or subjects-daily data,
so you can see a lot of movement.
And that's starting again.
And now what's going to happen,
it's going to tilt on its side
in a moment, and you
can start seeing this
as a function of depth in the ocean.
So there you go, so now you're
not just seeing the surface,
but you're seeing the situation
under the ocean's surface.
And that's starting again
now in January 2015,
and you can see how the anomalies
are building up in the lower layers,
then really moving over
to the ocean's surface
as the event matures.
So it's November.
It's now a very mature El Nino
event in January and February.
And stops there.
It's already dying off a little bit.
Yeah, you see, you
can put it to January.
So you know, we've peaked
here, and that's dying out now.
But this is, you know, that's
basically a summary diagram
of what happened this year based
on our best estimates using
as many observations
as we could use.
Now, I was -- I would just
talk about the drought
in California at this point.
The view from space.
So essentially, this is a NASA
view of the drought in California.
It's essentially looking at the
vegetation derived by MODIS,
which is an instrument on
the EOS Aqua satellite.
And essentially, anything
brown means
that there's way less vegetation
there than there should be.
And so compare this with
maps of high temperatures.
This essentially means, you
know, it's been hot, dry.
The plants haven't survived.
So we're on strong anomaly
there down, you know,
through much of the West Coast,
in the mountains close
to the coast as well.
So when we heard about this big El
Nino coming, there's been precedents
in the past to say okay, a
large El Nino means a lot
of rainfall in California.
And so has there been
rainfall in California?
Well, here's another view.
This is NASA's GPN satellite.
This is essentially going to build
up showing you accumulated rainfall
over each month for
November, December.
No, sorry.
December, January, and February.
And yes, you can see we got
quite a lot of precipitation
on the northern part of the West
Coast, but really not a huge lot
over the Sierra Nevada
in Southern California.
We got plenty on the Gulf
Coast, you know, some storms.
And you're going to see one event
that we got, the snowfall event,
and you know, which was a
typical East Coast storm.
So on the basis of this, at
least until mid-February,
there have not been a huge
lot of rain in California.
And this is a map again from
NOA sort of summarizing.
It's the average precipitation
between December,
over December, January,
and February.
And typically in a strong El Nino
year, it's a little cooler up here,
warmer down here, and
blue here means wetter.
So a lot more rain
on the West Coast,
and typically across
the Gulf Coast, too.
It's kind of well-known the Gulf
of Mexico gets pretty wet
in the El Nino events.
And also people thought
this year, 2015-2016,
not so much rain over in the Gulf.
Not enough, particularly wet.
Also not a whole lot
of rain in California.
There's been a lot of rain
in the Pacific Northwest,
but not so much in California.
So really we haven't had this
massive deluge throughout the
entire winter.
I think though since this
map was made, there has --
there was actually some fairly
severe rainfall just a couple
of weeks ago, so that
didn't make this map.
But in general, this idea that
a strong El Nino means a lot
of rain throughout the winter
in California is not
holding up this year.
Now, there's a couple
possible reasons for that.
One of them might be that warm blob
off the coast that's keeping things
warm out there and directing the
storm tracks slightly differently
than normal.
But more generally, I think
our knowledge of El Ninos
and their impacts on North
American rainfall is actually based
on very few events.
It may just be that every
single one of them, you know,
just like the events themselves,
each one is very different.
Maybe the response in the higher
latitudes is also affected
by other factors.
Just the positions of
the waves that affect
where the storm tracks go, and that.
So I think it's not
such a clear-cut thing
that strong El Nino automatically
means rain in California.
And we've known for a long time
that moderately sized El Nino,
there's really no correlation
between California,
Northern California and
rainfall and the El Nino pattern.
So, you know, we're probably
in the situation where we have
so few large events that we
don't know statistically what
really happens.
So the summary and outlook:
I'm trying to keep this short.
We do have a broad
understanding of El Nino
and its importance in
climate variability.
I've tried to give you a few
examples today of, you know,
about the structure of El Nino
itself, and the long-term effects.
To do that thoroughly, you
could have a lecture every week
for three months, and you know,
I think that would be too much.
So you know, I can encourage people
to just to go away and take a look.
And the traditional viewpoint
of the measurements from ships
and from the ground is supplemented
by NASA satellite observations.
And essentially with that, we're
able to get global observations
of many different quantities
that we can put today using our
complex data simulation systems.
And in that way, we can
build more complete pictures
of the entire earth system
and how different processes
start interacting.
And that's one of the
more, you know, for me,
that's the really interesting
part about this right now.
We've got essentially
an unprecedented number
of satellites flying, and we're
able to see so many different parts
of the earth's system now
than we could a few years ago.
But, you know, this is
a very exciting time
to be working in this science.
You know, barely touched on the
broad spectrum of NASA observations
of the earth's system, but I
hope I've given you some flavor
of what we have.
And even despite all this, I think
there are a number of points where,
you know, our understanding
isn't all there.
And so what we're really trying
to do is bring together
these satellite observations
with the models so that we
can improve the representation
of processes and improve the
fidelity of these predictions,
not only of the nine months seasonal
forecasts, but all the IPCC models
that do climates assessments.
Some of those have, you know,
reasonably good El
Nino representation.
Some of them, it's too weak,
or some it's too strong.
Some of them, it hits the
wrong, periodicities and things.
And that got better between the
2007 and 2013 climate reports,
but they're still not there.
So there's really a great hope
that we can use our observations
to improve these models and come up
with a better prediction of climate
and the role of El Nino in climate.
And also even the role of El Nino
in a changing climate
isn't well understood.
You know, we know surface
temperatures are warming.
We've had this general temperature
increase, even basic things now,
like if we're looking at a 40-year
time series, we can't assume
that the average El Nino is
not affected by climate change.
We need to stop thinking that
the average should be something
that increases slowly with
time, and then we might come
up with slightly different
conclusions
of how these things happen.
You know, so I think those
are some of the things
that I'm hoping we can use
NASA satellite observations
to address in the future.
I just want to thank everyone
here as well as my colleagues,
our funding and computing
center in particular.
We keep them really
busy with our things.
And I'll end up with some contact
information if anyone needs it.
So I'd like to thank you very much
for your attention,
and thanks for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus: You probably
have had all your questions
answered, but if there are a
few more, we can take them.
And when you ask a question,
if you would repeat it
so everybody [inaudible]
on the recording.
>> Steve Pawson: On
the recording, yes.
>> Steve, what's your
general thinking
about as the climate gets
warmer, ocean water gets warmer.
Is that -- ?
>> Steve Pawson: You know, I
mean, El Ninos have been happening
for as far back as
we've had observations.
And people have even gone back
thousands of years and used records
of sediments on the ocean floor.
They've used tree rings,
they've used many things,
and you can reconstruct
these climate fluctuations
that are El Nino-like.
So El Nino's been around
for a long time.
It's going to persist into the
future, and then the basic mechanism
of El Nino, you know, taking that
warm water from here and moving it
over here is probably
not going to change.
But the difference could be
either if you're just in general,
if you're a degree or two warmer,
then the response is nonlinear.
So triggering clouds is not --
isn't, you know, that could change
because even though you're colder
than normal, you could still be
above the temperature where
you're triggering clouds
if your climate has changed a lot.
So, you know, things could
change in their responses.
And I think that's a
very interesting type
of question to be looking at.
>> Stephanie Marcus: You can choose.
>> Steve Pawson: Yeah.
Okay, yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yeah, that's right.
So the question then
about the accuracy
about the three centimeter
measurement
of the sea surface height
when waves are much larger.
And yet waves, waves
are a separate thing.
We can try to model waves separately
from the actual mean height
of the ocean that's being looked at.
So I think that if there is
some element of time averaging
when a wave moves through,
and you get an average
of what's there without the wave.
So getting that reference, you know,
that reference height is
very critical to this,
and not measuring the
crest of a wave.
You're absolutely right, yes.
>> Well does the satellite
have sufficient time resolution
to be able to do that
average over a wave.
>> Steve Pawson: Yeah,
usually the satellites,
you can do it in two ways.
First of all, if the
observation window is long enough,
the wave just moves through anyway.
But if you're not having
the wave move through,
then you basically aggregate over
several measurements to get rid
of the shorter scale signatures.
And that's a very, that's a
very normal way of dealing
with fast changes in
satellite observations.
>> I have a question.
How does the satellite measure
the salinity of the water?
>> Steve Pawson: That's
measuring emissions of light
at particular wavelengths,
and that emission is affected
by how much salt is in the water.
>> Okay.
>> One more?
>> What's the relation
between El Nino
and the salinity of
the ocean, if any?
>> Steve Pawson: Okay,
so it's fairly complex.
Essentially, the salinity
of the tropical ocean is
in part determined by rainfall.
So through an El Nino event, the
rain will move because it's raining
where it's warmest over the ocean.
So essentially your freshwater,
the non-salty water is getting put
into the ocean in different places.
So that probably the
most basic aspect
of the salinity that we can see.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Well,
it's been very interesting,
and I think the next party we
can go to, we will be the center
of attention with all
of our new knowledge.
We want to thank you so much!
>> Steve Pawson: Okay,
well thank you, too.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.